[Music]
that was very nice
[Music]
we empty out all the money in the cash
register
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
that was a silent slurp because it's a
somber moment not really that somber
look
i'm pissed yeah so
uh sponsors today none uh introducing uh
dave landau
gerald i don't care ahoy um shut up
no damn it
no look uh this is where we are for
people who are watching uh there's going
to be a lot of information here
i don't know where this will be uh where
it'll be available so um listen the
hashtag right now if you uh
want to get out there's free crowd or
just include my name tweet this live
stream out
um there is the prom people say why
don't you create another platform
because i'm going to talk about being
blocked on twitter
and what's been happening and my
application lawyer is going to be here
in a second
uh it's mug club you're a lot of
credit.com club and the promo code is
fight like hell you get 30
off that's what allows us to be on all
these platforms
that consistently try to ban us so let
me explain to you
exactly what happened uh yesterday uh i
was
locked out of twitter i found that out
late at night
yeah um for posting yesterday the
segment that you saw
where uh we went to the fake addresses
the addresses
in the nevada in michigan voter rolls
that didn't exist for those who didn't
watch yesterday you can see the link in
the description but here's just a
snapshot of the addresses
fake fake like a kardashian spin-off
um we show them they're available at
live credit.com
uh just to be clear twitter banned this
and then now it's available but you
can't interact with it i don't know
exactly what the rules are
saying that we violated guidelines look
i want to be very clear about something
especially to the
you know and i understand a lot of
people out there who want to be patriots
who are trump supporters and say well
why don't you look
i cannot claim that donald trump won the
election
because i cannot verify that i cannot
claim
that all of this was rigged by the
because i cannot verify that
i cannot claim factual evidence of
motive
because i can't verify it what i can
tell you
is what is and what i can tell you is we
have
hundreds more of these addresses and
when twitter says
unverified election fraud
the segment was verifying that's exactly
what it was it was
let me let me walk you through the steps
okay here's what we did and i'm going to
bring on my
half asian lawyer in a second to talk
about it because i understand i don't
want to be hoodwinked
we've talked about some false data
that's been presented before in relation
to election fraud and grandiose claims
we've made none of that it's almost been
a running joke
because we want to point out how absurd
and stringent the rules are and the
burden of proof
what did we do in finding these
addresses and we have we have hundreds
more listen you comment below
let me know if you the best thing you
can do is you know tweet this out and
comment you let me know do you want me
to stop doing the show for a few weeks
and just collect hundreds of these i can
do that i can drive around the country
in an rv we could potentially
collect thousands it's just a matter of
time
here's what we did we accumu step one we
accumulated the voter data okay from
government websites
all right so don't say this is
unverified this was us going through the
process of verification
which many state election boards didn't
care to do
can't state the mode of why there's also
some new information one of those fake
voters who was a clinton staffer
which we'll get to in a second i didn't
know that on everybody said i can't
place your face
but her name rings a bell cherry
interesting then we checked the
addresses to see if they were
deliverable by ups
okay then we checked to see if there was
a registered property
at that address and then we physically
visited
uh in this case i had health problems so
we sent some people out dave landau was
was very acquiescent we had an intern we
have other people
we could do this across country we
physically visited set address
and gave you the name of the voter from
the address that doesn't exist
that is the verification process someone
else in charge
should be doing this the issue is the
people who are in charge
not only those in government but more
powerful than government and twitter
say that's not allowed
we're not allowed this to be clear
because there are a lot of people out
there who make claims
donald trump won the election one nation
under god look you can't make that claim
if you can't verify it
i will stand by this and it's not just
about my account being unlocked it
happened in record time
uh that post needs to be up because that
is
hard factual information and i would
swear to it and i'd stick my reputation
on
this isn't about me i'm willing to stand
in that line of fire for
the truth not for a lie so we will only
discuss what we can verify that's
precisely what this segment was
was going through a verification process
very stringently due diligence and
twitter
removed that anyway
what are the limitations at that point
this is literally saying you cannot go
through a process which would actually
make most journalists blush
and verify false election addresses and
post it publicly
we will not allow that then what opinion
can someone have
can it only be unfounded opinions as it
relates to election like the new york
times
or time magazine because i don't know
how you get more factual
than this and so to speak about this and
the policy in the guidelines so you guys
can understand better
uh we have my half asian lawyer uh bill
richmond
who is here to talk about this today
[Music]
a um more information again that promo
code is fight like hell you can join my
club live.com
mug club uh half asian librarian how are
you sir
oh let's get let's get it let's get his
microphone on there in the two minute
all right now we can hear you
how's it going you did powder yourself
before the show i know don't i look like
moderately better yeah well you just
don't listen as much
it's like you have a nice pregnant glow
i thought i only hit a powder myself at
home
you know when my wife was like oh god go
powder yourself um
so can you explain to people what
happened here because we
they need to understand the twitter
guidelines i guess let's walk through
this first off you reached out to
twitter
right yes okay so we reached out to
twitter um
we followed through the normal procedure
that they have which is a laughable
procedure with regards to appeal that
occurred last night as well
so but what we have at a fundamental
level without being legalese about it is
[ __ ]
um in the legal in the legal context
though
by the way i love how i tell everyone
here i'm like look be on your best
behavior until bill
my lawyer leaves because i don't he has
to walk into court and he comes of
course
[Laughter]
they're full of it all right but there
is there is a time and a place and any
lawyer
any judge any person will know you have
to call a spade a spade now in a
courtroom i won't say it that way i'm
going to use
the you know that that's 100 words that
are that keep me
employed but no no i mean but what it
comes down to is they have said
these are the this is the process we
will tell you why your tweets are
restricted
here are our policies read them love
them
follow them and we will only act in
these ways
this is called fraud right this is when
you say i have a platform that has
certain rules and if you play by the
rules
we'll let you play right but then you
change the rules did they answer you
what guidelines we violated because it
was just broad stroke
not only was there no answer but i mean
you've already tweeted this
when they sent the original restriction
it says
specifically colon blank
form their form shutdown notice has a
place for them to tell you why they're
shutting you down
and someone looked at that and goes
let's keep them guessing yeah
send and listen i've always i don't like
to talk about numbers i want the content
to speak for itself but of course it's
on the radar of the higher ups when this
is something that has millions of plays
and views yeah okay yeah
and i was like oh some it was some patsy
for that no these were the higher-ups
let me
read here uh twitter's their civic
integrity rules
regarding misleading information about
outcomes that's how they frame it
we know with youtube you can talk about
voter fraud right you can talk about
voter fraud occurring on a large scale a
massive scale
you cannot in any way imply that that
affected
the outcome of the 2020 election
you can with elections in 2016. which
we'll get to
right right um so it says we will label
or remove false or misleading
information intended to undermine public
confidence in an election or other civic
process
this includes but is not limited to
disputed claims that could undermine
faith in the process itself such as
unverified information about election
rigging ballot tampering vote tallying
or certification of election results
i don't know how physically visiting
addresses
and posting that they don't exist with
names of people in some cases who are in
prison
is undermining faith it almost seems
like this is designed to
instill faith people in themselves to
try and hold their elected
officials accountable well this is the
example we talked about before which is
think about think about the governments
or the processes
or anyone who says you know what would
make you feel good
about this process is if i ignore all of
the problems
the evidence of problems i cover them up
and if you raise
any question about them i shoot you and
i put you in a gulag right
sounds like some countries that we don't
like yeah it sounds like some processes
we don't like
and this is really what it comes down to
is you have spent an extensive amount of
time looking at these rules as the rules
get updated and changed
you know no matter how much we may
disagree with them you understand you're
pro-business you say okay
right you're going to put out these
rules well we're going to play by them
and when you play by the rules they
decide they go
oh well we don't have a good reason uh
let's just no reason let's just
remove it speaking of that's actually
where um that's where uh
dorsey vacation this summer i didn't
actually mean shut up dave i was just
trying
i i didn't know okay
i'm verified i feel like somebody like
you hit me and you're my dad
and i should just get in right from
there yeah we're also nice to go out to
dairy queen like that's my makeup but
i'm not gonna address it yeah
my dad's like a great job out there in
right field not catching anything
he's like dave just keep going further
no no be on the wall okay next county
all right
i'm sorry i hit your mom but uh listen
this tin roof sunday uh expresses all i
need to say
wrong brother died so they say
unverified well hold on a second
who verifies it that yeah if we go
through voter rolls see if it's
deliverable
and then go and physically visit the
address this address isn't there it's
immediate
yeah it's and some people say well those
were those were temporary voting booth
setups
voter registration setups because of
covet in the middle of a freeway
i mean pl in the middle of an apartment
complex with a number that doesn't exist
right who
the entire complex didn't exist in the
middle of mexican town
three feet away from a sign where a
guy's wanted for murder
i i do have best place i do find this to
be you know
a really interesting question which is
if you don't let verified information on
right but you don't verify any of the
information
nobody gets to talk about anything right
yeah is there a pro can we send do we
need to send to twitter the voter roles
i mean because
we've made it all publicly available
again vladimir.com you can go see we're
the only show that i know that provides
all of our sources you may not like them
but we provided them yeah absolutely and
here's here's what i do like when you
get to the bigger context of what this
looks like if
if what they're saying is well you know
what we really need to do is we need to
vet this information we need to know if
it's verified or unverified and
sure if you want to send us some
information we'll take a look at it you
know i don't know that sounds like what
random house does right it sounds like
what a publisher does
oh i i i decide i want to look at the
content
they they are somebody's legal
they are walking backwards into
the very thing they're trying to avoid
and what is unclear is
are they are they so oblivious to that
that they're letting it happen
or do they know that it's happening and
for some reason they're unafraid of that
consequence well i think it's important
again for people to know there are
people who have made claims we've been
very careful yeah exactly they'll sit me
down and says you literally can't make
that claim
even if you do google earth until you
people
physically go there and confront which
is absurd all the new york times needs
to do is say
ah there's no evidence of voter fraud
all they need to do and they won't be
fact checked to say
ah this video that credit releases
bullcrap we'll give them the voter rules
we'll give them the name they can watch
the show
it doesn't matter so the verification
thing doesn't hold up let me move
through uh some of the other
any possibility here of how we've run a
foul
uh the fact check under my tweet
included you know there's a risk
of violence what
yeah i'm sorry what a risk of violence
was that was there any incitement to
violence there
i don't know if you no just to be clear
no no i don't think anything are they
trying to say because
some people stormed the capital at some
point that me showing a voting address
that doesn't exist is inciting people to
violence when we've consistently told
people to not be violent
as a matter of fact condemned violence
has it caused billions of dollars in
damages
across this country and raised six
figures for a foundation for david
i'm sorry didn't we just engage an
entire multi-day uh theater
over impeaching the president based on
evidence that he was the one that caused
it
right so yeah he's the one that caused
it it wasn't tweets
it wasn't other speakers it wasn't
articles it wasn't questioning a system
to make sure that the system is good
everyone on
every side of this issue every person in
america
loves america wants to come to a great
america wants to make sure that our
voting systems are good and if we can
raise questions if we can't raise
questions no i agree with that i don't
know
everyone else well we didn't even we
didn't even use the inflammatory word
peacefully
in that show i mean we would we stayed
way away from people we stayed from even
addressing you can't say that because
they say if you say peacefully it's a
dog whistle i mean violently
right the neighborhoods i was in were
pretty violent
that's why i put the sunglasses on
halfway there like i love how dave was
trying to pretend like he wasn't filming
himself he was like oh so i don't know
what's this uh he's like fixing his nose
he's trimming his nose hairs with a
gillette
hey hey what are you doing no nothing
i'm just doing no no oh i got no tails
too man you cross forward and you lose
hair in the head get on your nose
i we we played a good round of spades
and then let me go yeah
nice hey dumbo's off your head
something else they said okay claiming
which we did not do claiming victory
before election results have been
certified uh is not
which we did not do i mean the election
results have already been certified but
what about yeah did we bring that up you
showed those yeah yeah people like uh
well that's their problem
yeah yeah but i think we have collage d
which is
kamala harris yep nancy pelosi claiming
victory before the election results had
been certified
so the rules that they used not only
could not apply to us at all
but they selectively didn't apply them
to people who would be violating them
they
claimed victory before the election was
certified did we do that i just want to
be clear
no okay kamala harris on november 7th
said we've won this election
definitively elegant
okay can i can i point out something
real quick yeah this is the danger that
everyone has to recognize when you put
so much power
into these tech companies who are then
paying
subcontractors minimum wage to review
the tweets if even that
they just got some ai bot chained up in
the back and telling them
screw all of the types of things that
are like that all right we don't like
those either but ultimately
this is the problem because there there
is no recourse there is no customer
service line there's no one
calling and saying hey i wanted to check
on that to see how it is their appeal
process goes into a black hole to be
reviewed by more robots or possibly
at some level people but what that means
is at this scale
they are simply unable to exercise their
ability to enforce their rules
in good faith you can't do it if you've
left it to robots that you can't really
figure out what they're doing yeah then
you aren't acting in good faith well and
if this post doesn't back up with full
interactivity then we know that it's not
in good faith because right
and i'll explain sort of i don't want to
say the trap but i'll explain what it is
that we've laid here we've we've gone to
great lengths to ensure that it does not
run off sometimes we'll go why do you
dance we're not dancing around it
we're not dancing on anything we're
making sure that we bet once and we bet
right
and if they violate their own guidelines
and their own enforcement and choose to
double down on it
now it's become their problem not ours
where we're relegated to some message
board or some alternative platform which
by the way if an alternative platform
out there
uh wants to mirror this youtube channel
let us know because there are a few out
there but i don't know if we've had
anyone reach out directly
so okay incitement to violence no uh
unverified election
no no final one that some people may try
and claim is oh uh doxing
which is actually we did the uh i didn't
even know this was the thing
maybe it'll go in urban dictionary we
anti-doxxed
there's there is no there then we
pointed out addresses
that don't exist you doctors targeted
harassment in
greek town in detroit i mean how does
this how does this so did we docks
did we try and tell indoctrinating by
the way is also with malicious intent
right sending someone to someone's house
well not only was there was there the
anti-doxing which i agree i like that
term
let's add it webster's but yeah but but
ultimately none of that was in the
twitter post
no no no that was in the post no not at
all right the post itself was a preview
about the show where the verification
was occurring right so when you look at
all of the different rules and the fact
that we're even having to go through all
of these
is emblematic of the problem they don't
tell you what the response they don't
tell you what the problem is
you have to guess what the problem is
even if you happen to guess what the
false problem is
there's no one to talk to about it and
there's no way to undo it but then
afterwards when it's all done maybe they
let you out of twitter jail
maybe they go but here remember this
anyone can go to your twitter channel
right now or go to your page and find
the tweet they just can't interact with
you yeah what if it was so
dangerous yeah it was so inciting to
violence if it was such a clear
violation of rules that you couldn't put
the reason in the email right
why is it still up if it was jeffrey
dahmer eating a guy in his you know
junior apartment
and they're like well you know what this
is a violation you can't show this we
just won't you can quote tweet it
i thought he had a two bedroom but he
it's a it's a one-bedroom with a junior
suite
that's one room it was a shrine of bones
yes
and butts yeah yeah you get a thing come
on
waste not want not well it just shows
clearly that their goal
is not to protect people from
misinformation their goal is to silence
political views that they disagree with
right we took
the safest possible route we talked
about this with other information coming
out from other people saying dominion
voting systems was the thing
that was difficult because it would
either take forever to prove or it would
be impossible to prove
right this was easy right it's illegal
to vote in a state you don't live in
we just looked at the addresses you
listed and they don't exist yeah and by
the way really quickly also eric
swalwell the
professional banger of chinese spies
yeah he did claim that's collage e here
uh oh he claimed that
he keeps calling me diddy really yeah
here put this on
i don't know it is a nice i don't like
negligence but it is silk
um let me be really clear here too with
what we've done like like i've said
comment below again
the best thing you can do right now is
put the hashtag out you know it could be
free credit just include my last name in
it because we were trending accidentally
thank you to tim pool for covering it
and by the way
yeah in this case credit where stu thank
you to youtube for not taking it down
but we understood what youtube's rules
were i think they're silly
but we but we still played by them and
they didn't selectively
enforce them um let me be really clear
about this here too
it doesn't mean that this is the only uh
uh
these are the only examples of election
fraud out there it's the only thing that
we can prove and that
you can actually verifiably prove for
example look what we can do and what we
did we said what is it that we could 100
percent testify to in court if we needed
to
go through the voter rules see if it's a
deliberate address see if it's the name
see if this person voted do all that
then go to the address
and see that it doesn't exist this is
the only thing we can prove
because it's the only place we can
physically visit now
this would be the smallest example of
any potential irregularities out there
there is no system that i can use to see
if
people voted illegal immigrants voted
there is no system i can actually use to
see if people voted
in separate states there is no system i
have available to me
as an entertainment host to see if the
paper ballots
match signatures i can't do that this is
the simplest and easiest one it's the
only thing that i could do
and i could do it to the tune of all
year never do another show just go to
addresses it just depends on what you
want me to do do you want us to take a
couple of weeks off and rent an rv
we can number this in the hundreds if we
confirm what we have on google earth but
again
google earth isn't enough new york times
can just say no voter fraud i don't
believe crowder
we can do it it's just a matter of time
um that's what's so scary
yeah and so basically we're also saying
that you can't do the same kind of due
diligence that ups does when you enter a
shipping address they verify it
immediately
the software exists you don't have to
create anything you just have to take
the time to do it and to say hey
votes should be legal people that live
here should be able to vote if you don't
live here by the way if you're changing
the rules
and you can claim an address on a median
fine let us know
i think there's a false equivalency here
me getting my amazon packages is way
more important that's true that's true
integrity you're right i apologize safe
secure elections
beautiful and brave got it i did doc's
offense
yeah i specifically love the house
between houses that doesn't exist that
one's the most ballsy i think yeah the
entire
time well one of them was the coleman
young center that one was that was fall
too yeah that was great really
that's where community comes together i
just if you can't do this look this is
the point
you can't question this isn't just
questioning authority
this is verifying something this is the
verification because no one else is
interested in going through the
verification
people say well why didn't you do this
first off i had health problems i was
going to what do
we have to do this show or do we have to
just drive across the country and do
this right yeah and
uh it took a while to get these to
actually verify these addresses it's a
multi-step process because
we have a target on our back i will
stand behind what we presented to you
100
and if there's a mistake i will correct
it absolutely and wouldn't you say like
hey
states if you've got a problem with this
address that we went to that didn't
exist and you say there's a house in the
field that's verified
let us know yeah you know where to find
us yeah
well not not physically physically but
online yeah
we around yeah so
i mean i mean it's becoming more absurd
but i but i do appreciate it right
i mean at least now you've got twitter
they're coming out of the shadows
they're they're doing
less of the you know we're going to put
a silent thumb behind the scale because
there are more eyes so now they're going
okay we're going to start sending some
emails we're going to tell you what's
going on and
every time they make a step like this
whether it's twitter or the other
platforms
they're showing how their steps are
mistaken right and then we can do
something more about it right
i mean so many people have said no no
they they don't do that
and you hear them testify in front of
congress we'll tell you why if you're
being restricted
we'll tell you why you're banned and
then you look at it and you go
they're not doing it they haven't told
you why let me be really clear rules
these are their i don't i couldn't care
less but and we don't want to people
know that we're following a lawsuit
against facebook i don't want to sue
twitter because they're the least
relevant of the platforms right
um i mean listen they're driving
themselves into the ground at this point
but i will say this this segment will be
uploaded to twitter because [ __ ] you
and uh also i don't really care about my
account
this post that's not enough for me this
post needs to be publicly available and
people need to be able
to to to remove that is to put your
thumb
on the scale of democracy on the scale
of this constitutional republic and
that's more important if they want to
put me in twitter jail
i would if they said look we'll give you
an agreement right now you can no longer
tweet
but we'll make sure that these posts
that this this this process you went
through
these segments where you verify
addresses will be up take your pick in a
heartbeat i am
tired right now of this of people being
so concerned about i couldn't care less
i was taken out of twitter jail so
quickly to be clear
yeah we just don't have an answer as to
what's going on with the post and it's
not enough
it's not enough we're coming for it it's
got to be available or you tell us what
is wrong
find something wrong with what we did
find something factually inaccurate
we fact checked you we fact checked the
people who didn't go through the
verification process
if we are wrong you need to prove it to
us otherwise
it's just silencing information that you
don't like is there anything else bill
because we're about to get some stuff
that could uh get everyone to try i'm
even afraid to lose out of the studio
because then more things are going to
happen but uh okay i guess i'll be back
all right okay
love you bye mr schwalwell's
[Laughter]
i think it's time for for governor greg
abbott i think it's time for ted cruz i
think it's
time for ben crenshaw have the same kind
of guts that florida's desantis had
right and saying big tech you can't do
this to people in our state right we're
in your state
you have to defend us because nobody
else is right now this can't be allowed
to happen
step up to the plate i'm tired of
ballless politicians yeah and you know
what i'll tell you what it's made our
job uh just as hard from people who want
to be patriots i understand but who
don't do their own due diligence
yeah you just say they believe every
single election fraud claim out there i
will
tell you that the this would definitely
be the tip of the iceberg yeah
if one and we're going to get to a
clinton staffer by the way who just
happened to be on that role in the show
but if one were to were to in any way
orchestrate or one were to plan to try
and not verify or be locked
with the rules yeah the the least
commonly used tool would be to just have
fake addresses more common would be
illegal immigrants more common would be
no signature verification more common
would be people underage people
who uh no one is paying attention to
people who are eligible to vote
felons so in one of those yesterday just
to be clear
in one of those it was someone who voted
from an address that didn't exist
who is currently in jail and his address
is currently listed as the county
sheriff
if if the government in i don't know if
that was nevada or michigan
if the government were that was michigan
if the government were able to verify
anything if they just did a cross
reference right and goes
uh okay well this vote came in does that
check out oh no right away
we oh he's been printed
he's currently with us it should just be
oh wait a second hold on a second this
guy has two addresses oh
he's in jail all right uh that one
doesn't count
i wonder how that clinton staffer is
going to kill themselves
yes yeah well you know what we don't
know i'll get we don't know
yet we have no idea uh what is it today
uh what did i have by the way what am i
promoting today
nothing nothing just comment uh put this
up on twitter facebook use my name in
there somewhere to get this training so
that people can
people can see the truth and that really
really isn't about me like i said i
would gladly give up my account that
post needs to be up this information
needs to be out there
and let me know yeah let me know if you
want me to stop doing the show for a
couple of weeks
and just collect more of these addresses
because we can do it for a very long at
what point is it considered massive do
we need to reach a thousand
yeah do we need to reach 200 400 because
if you had a team of people doing this
you could collect it i just can't make
that claim because of these rules
because i'm not time magazine
right well it's kind of like trump's
lawyer when he was talking to that abc
lady saying so you're okay with just a
little bit of doctored evidence so
are you okay with a little bit of voter
fraud that's just a little
like where's the line for you guys we
got 20 with
an asian intern who was listening to
house music and horrible peripheral
vision and a stand-up comedian from
detroit
yes yeah period because we're like yeah
this is this is in our spare time
investigative journalism at its finest
and by the way while we're talking about
election fraud and we're talking about
the standards it also
dinesh d'souza uh did he had a great
quote when he was on my show he said
it's not about
is there enforcement of the law it's is
the law enforced
equally right which i would love like i
just i can't imagine him ordering at
chipotle
i don't want the guacamole i don't want
it i know it's a scam
and hillary clinton is a communist
demonic figure okay listen
we recommend you go to cudoba i don't
want cordova
it sucks i'm just saying hey they put
hormones in it
and that's so you want a number three
yeah
as many hormones as possible i need to
widen
the shoulders and john malkovich
john malkovich when i was your age we
didn't have chipotle
we would suck on pennies and considered
it a delight
my best movie is where i play cyrus the
virus
in conair and i'm
horrible at doing a russian accent
despite
being from russia i have an oreo tell
how would you not notice that i do well
when i eat an
oreo listen i didn't get it early okay
russian so let's go is it applied
equally what action did twitter take by
the way this is what matters to people
out there you don't go out half informed
what did twitter do with the russian
collusion hoax and uh the mueller report
well look we have right now before
right before the who is not guilty well
let's look at and then we have a clip
from
after what's been allowed on twitter
there was a clear
intent to collude with the russians
there was a willingness to receive
russian help
the president himself called on the
russians to assist his campaign by
hacking hillary clinton's emails it
wasn't until there was a recess
in the intel committee that he started
to walk some of that back
why is bill who got to him i don't know
who talked to him but that was very odd
what
he did no you can tell by the powder oh
you're right
it's almost as if the the mueller report
hadn't come out yeah
it doesn't matter they lived in like a
time capsule that was before so we've
talked about the rule of law doesn't
matter this thing they don't follow the
law these social media companies for
example
um well let me let me get back to that
remind me why what story i want to get
back to but uh
let's also go to how twitter has covered
fraud those are all available on twitter
by the way those clips those people ted
liu i wish
i wish i loved anything as much as ted
lou
loves being a prick now is that adult
um that adult behavior
[Laughter]
twitter uh how do they cover here's
something too uh
allegations of fraud in other countries
yeah so um they allow it to be covered
by the way no disclaimers no fact checks
belarus and here's what's interesting on
twitter about belarus uh this is overlay
h
the claims of poll workers in belarus
nearly identical to not the claims what
we observed with americans by the way
did you see all the poll workers being
turned away they allow it on belarus
they don't allow it here in the united
states they don't consider it evidence
again it's not supplied equally maybe
because twitter is more of a third world
sort of app
two in ten use them in the united states
eight and ten uh in saudi arabia use
twitter oh well actually poll workers in
belarus are masseuses
that's true that's what they say
i will massage you and then they will
make you never have children
yes oh geez that's not part of the power
it is a freebie i throw it in you want
to fight in shower
yes
[Laughter]
best training technically it is bath
house it's more like a
steam room and not really but for
america and i say shower the point is
i will butterfly knife your [ __ ] he's
not gay if you have tattoo of
rem reaper holding babies that's not
which you may think is not toughest
tattoo but i assure you grim reaper
holding baby
is toughest tattoo be very tough uh
right now alexander million is going hey
so
[Laughter]
let me read you a claim of the belarus
poll workers vadim korozurizov who
worked at another minsk polling station
told
the alternative press that he didn't
even get to the signing stage a senior
poll worker dismissed him after he
pointed out violations during the count
one said she was asked to sign the final
protocol a document summing up the vote
totals each precinct much display after
counting the ballots before voting even
ended
with the totals left blank she said i
wouldn't sign the protocol because it's
a crime
it's fraud even in pillow rules and we
really don't care about crime
venezuela what did they do in venezuela
on twitter uh
the election of course was fraudulent
you know if anyone here has heard of
maduro right
no you people can just make general
claims about fraudulent elections and
again i'm saying
the claims are less specific they're
less verified than what we've talked
about here in the united states because
we haven't said election fraud we've
said voter fraud period yeah election
fraud would mean it comes from the top
which i can't make i would never explain
that exactly
we'll get to this clinton staffer who we
just happened to include in the voter
rolls in a little bit but i would never
claim that it comes from
the top no no i would just say what we
can verify what
you would never say so
russia going back to russia right the
russian elections uh here you go they
let this be covered in russia
an election for constitutional amendment
saw some precincts approaching 100
yes votes by the way comparable to some
precincts in detroit
yes yeah well of course it was after
everyone went to bed
right yeah well so look here's something
i want everyone to do
okay try it for yourself what i want you
to do is go to your go to your local
election websites
check out some addresses and um we have
the steps as to what you can do at live
earthquaker.com the steps that you can
follow to verify see if it's a
deliverable address and then see if and
just use google earth we don't want you
driving around neighborhoods no we don't
want you
at all bothering anyone at their homes
we made sure that we did that that's why
a lot of them came from industrial areas
we have some others that were in more
municipal areas where
places didn't exist but we just didn't
want to bother people and
landau was cuddly not intimidating it's
true and i didn't want to bother anybody
at their median or uh government bill of
course of course
you never know who you're going to run
into under the underpass that's sure
right
never do you need to be careful but one
can assume it won't be
cordial no not at all um i guess
elections matter more in those countries
than they do here where
twitter was founded and has its home
right right you would think
apparently venezuela is a big clientele
there really they're just trying to eat
their smartphones that's true
i thought i thought this one i thought
this was fruit ninja
it's got good minerality
[Music]
these are countries where they take the
finger looking good slogan literally and
they
walk out of kfc without thumbs there's a
goof
by the way hit the notification bell if
you're subscribed
that's why fonzie doesn't eat there am i
right hey
he just yeah fonzie and venezuela just
goes no
right by the way so i want to bring
something up about your tweet if
now is a good time right because you
said you want interaction with that so
you can't
thank you you can't comment on it right
now at all and you can't like it those
are two things that help
get your tweet out in public eye people
seeing
verified elections you verified voter
fraud only quote retweet it and then
you're given all kinds of you know
flashing screens and warnings to make
sure are you sure you want to do this
i just happen to remember a story i
think a
reputable newspaper published hacked
information from donald trump's tax
returns the reason we know attacked he
spent four years telling people to go
screw themselves and gave him the finger
and two weeks later put an entire
newspaper
locked out because their story was right
not only that came back and said hey
that was our bad but by the way we will
not let them
have that tweet back it doesn't come
back you can repost again now but you
can't come back
you can't get it back same thing that
happened with facebook you can't get
that momentum back
on these things yes and they know it
right just like removing our election
stream so guys yeah
sorry someone in bangladesh got it wrong
why are you always blaming
the bangla they're nice people bradley
smith bradley smith that's right
they just take you out at the knees like
nancy kerrigan
that's true you know i don't mean to be
timely sorry
[Laughter]
searing commentary um
don't call him the best color man of the
business that's what i do
i make it relevant he's like don cherry
we're all saying he's gonna be yelling
about the
swedes yep uh they get swedes they cross
check him okay don all right got it
i understand i don't think you
understand anything so uh well as we go
on with factual information of course it
is
a lot of people don't know this we
celebrate our brothers and sisters we
had to get to that first but it is of
course black history month
still in arabic i don't know yeah um and
uh what do we have uh you had a fact
about uh
i got it today tragically you know tiger
woods got an accident that wasn't today
that was yes it was yesterday but
you know it's black history month he
doesn't go a day without the ganja yeah
so
yeah of course um times are continuing
and uh tiger woods is actually
mostly asian so yeah it's more like an
anti-history
that would explain the driving
but that's not just that i wasn't
that's him that's on him well no it's
just you know it's too soon
sorry i had to make up for that kerrigan
line everybody
oh too soon too soon just listen listen
no it's not to
okay there's always something to glean
from from there's a lesson okay
with tiger woods don't sext mistresses
and drive
it's true it's not safe uh here's
something else as far as so don't veer
off the road
yeah that's a good start it's what we
call a good start
or as many asian drivers call it huh
yeah so
uh a study here general is going to be
insuring you in no time
the change that seems like a great quote
you can get online call the general no
no no no
it's closed disclaimer everyone but
tiger woods
oh sorry we can't hear you
[Laughter]
all right so look here's something that
actually really interested me this is
just just a palette cleanser uh study
from the ecological society of america
why are you showing that guy yeah good
lord i got to get him off you and your
purple haze
uh they released underwater video
footage this is something of octopuses
in the wild they thought
hunting but octopi they now know is a
part of their behavior i don't know why
and they don't necessarily know why
they punch fish sometimes without reason
and i
this just really i was fascinated by
this we have a clip octopuses
punching fish look at this there's the
octopus
look that's a no-look jab they're evil
here
look at this the octopus they're the
bullies of the ocean
and they've been seeing this more and
more and it's been getting pretty like
they're going
why is this happening because it's not
necessarily hunting it's a predator it's
just doing this maliciously not to
mention what happens in the black sea
what kind of animal was that holding the
camera
the reason i tried to move on from your
tagger because i knew this was coming up
yeah and i thought it might be too heavy
it's fair you need a little space
so i apologize i wanted to laugh more
than i did that's so
funny i just love the idea of like
disney
you know you basically like chris rock
doing it he's doing a fish voice
listen listen i want to be where the
people
are
[Laughter]
oh my god that made me laugh way too
hard
while a guy yells world star so here's
something else that we we just
discovered too by the way
um so yesterday on air we discovered
that one of the voters was a felon right
currently incarcerated i believe you
found out when we did yeah we i found
out what you did
same thing we learned together don't
take my word for it
i think levar burton's uh uh
six-year-old consultant
yeah that's a baller forwarding address
by the way so uh one of them that we
talked about yesterday was christina joy
ruaya
a fake voter i believe in nevada
and uh here is a clip from us covering
it yesterday
this is christina joy rayagupana
hopefully i'm getting that right
voted from 353 west bonneville avenue
now
wait what was that house i don't know
bring that back up can you pause it
because it was so short so no we don't
need to look
okay so there you go there's the paper
what is this what is this explain this
to me
this is what i think is the worst one so
it was like right in a highway underpass
so wow i was in the middle of the street
like trying to take this video so i
like didn't take it that long because
maybe there wasn't even a way to pull
over
yeah like there was nothing there like
the closest one it's a dangerous
question in retrospect like right
up at the end of that and there was a
government building but the thing is all
private parking so i couldn't actually
park there and walk down or i had to
park like
20 minute walk away so potentially maybe
we have to someone could have voted from
that
government building may have been the
address uh no like
literally literally when i looked it up
like when i looked it up on my car gps
and on uh google maps it literally
pointed to that highway like underpass
wow wow in retrospect okay sending out
the asian intern to dude was
probably not our best call because troy
jr is now dead
that's too bad that is true he will not
be missed um on the roadways so here's
what we're talking about
we were talking about asking him to pull
over yeah
it's almost like i'm an oracle um
[Laughter]
christina joy rayagupon and then
afterwards the name rang about here's
actually a clip and i'm going to get to
something very interesting clinton
staffer for this area but it rang a bell
from a clip from james o'keefe i think
from like four or five
years ago so i just went in there and
gave him the form and he filled it out
okay so whatever yeah do whatever
whatever you can get away with just do
it
until you get kicked out like totally
yeah like within the law
we talk about ask for forgiveness not
for permission
i'm surrounded by asians today
everywhere
um so let me give you a little bit she
was a campaign uh
she was a clinton campaign staffer in
2015. okay
then gupana went missing after she was
caught breaking
campaign laws and she was investigating
wow okay uh
well they did just say break laws then
ask
sorry i didn't know that was coming i
didn't know what's coming either
so she was invested she was she was
caught breaking campaign laws and then
investigated by
nevada officials disappeared where
in the world
we put in a lot of work dave don't yeah
that's a lot
i didn't want to ruin it you hear the
mixing of that it was great it was
really good i almost danced
almost i was just laying down cardboard
i didn't realize
it's getting my boombox ready yeah so
here's something else it gets even worse
look
her postal address so this lady was a
campaign staffer in 2015 disappeared
because she broke the laws
her voting address was in nevada that we
covered there yesterday a person
who we don't even know if they've
or they went to a really nice farm um
but her new postal address we had sarah
brilliant sarah from uh uh
the uk uh do this research for us new
postal address is actually
listed as being in london while her most
recent social media posts
uh posts place her in places like uh the
philippines
sparring with pacquiao um here's
something else that's interesting
her london address is fake too what
so look let me ask you this let me let
me ask you this really let's just give
me one second here to be to be serious
and we'll go back to
you know reaganomics um where in the
world
is christina i'm trying to answer it
this was a clinton staffer in 2015 who
violated
laws right worked on the election right
uh in nevada
was investigated disappeared went to
london where there is actually a fake
address she seems to be in the
philippines and now she is voting don't
play it anymore to land
she is she is voting from nevada
this name in nevada from an address that
doesn't exist now
that is what i just told you is come at
me twitter i got a half asian in the
green room who's putting on too much
powder right now
my transgender prostitute is here
[Laughter]
i'll be right back see you guys in three
fun minutes the retainer is very
expensive
that's more of a catch-all yeah so let
me ask you this though someone again let
me reiterate
2015 violated laws worked as a clinton
uh clinton campaign staffer in nevada
investigator for breaking laws
disappeared
london fake address then her name shows
up at an address that doesn't exist that
is there's no denying that's a fact
the question becomes and i cannot answer
this who
if someone because someone else entered
in this vote
yeah who would be motivated or who would
think that this is the kind of
information
no one would think to double check just
take someone who worked for
the clinton staff campaign was
investigated who hasn't been in the
country for years
it doesn't have a real address in uh
london let's pop her name in an address
that doesn't exist
in nevada mitch mcconnell he probably
did it yeah
follow like a like the back of a
children's menu [ __ ] who
i can't that is everything i just told
you is she's not in the country
london address isn't real voted from a
place that doesn't exist in nevada
how does that happen yeah and by the way
it's almost as if we had our own videos
saying push these laws until you get
caught it's like she's doing what she
said right she
should do exactly what she's like
schweizy and ghost only instead of
pottery it's just voter fraud yeah some
of those uh
children's menus pretty enough tough nut
to cry
what's different between one and two the
mole
no two nose rings i might as well just
color in the maze i'm like there's no
way out of here
i ever tell you they thought my brother
was on they thought he was learning
disabled
and they brought him in to do the test
and he did that map faster than anyone
in the history of the children's
hospital had done really
they're like yeah your son's not
[ __ ] he's just really lazy
uh it was really bored with school
that's all it was so look my doctor
actually told my parents both
really yeah they were like he's a lazy
[ __ ]
it's the best of both worlds which
really what do you mean
look in 1982 that was a real diagnosis
yeah it's like if you're asking me my
look
i was here what i want to tell you is
okay if you're asking for my clinical
diagnosis
he's a lazy [ __ ] now if you're asking
for my opinion
the deck stacked against him yes okay if
you want my other opinion
he's hot
the way he filled in those colors i
thought i needed pills till he walked in
so let's uh
we'll move on here from twitter but
again the best thing you guys can just
do is comment you know
you let me know would you rather me
continue doing the this show or leave
for a while and just collect more votes
because look here's one thing to the
people understand
i get that it's a losing battle i
understand there's no system in place
to uh put into place uh if you actually
found enough evidence for i know there's
it doesn't matter because you know what
this matters for 2022. this matters for
2024.
if you don't know that your vote counts
look we just showed you
20 of your votes right now watching in
nevada 20 of your votes
wiped off they don't exist at least 20
we've got a list of far more
at what point does it matter a thousand
2 5
500 000 my vote's pretty important to me
yeah it doesn't take a whole lot to
swing elections either i'm not saying
that it did in this case we're just like
it doesn't take a while to do it and by
the way what people should do right now
go to that original post that is on your
page on twitter right now
quote retweet it with the hashtag
freecrowder but also
tag your elected officials in it let
them know that this is going on if
tons and tons and tons of people do that
they have to respond at some point you
hear that swallow get off the chinese
spy
get out and do your job i've got another
one convinced i have power
it is amazing how many times in all
seriousness you have to preface it with
saying i'm not saying the election
i'm stolen yeah when on the other side
against trump you could just write
whatever the hell you wanted yeah you
had a guy trying to impeach him who was
banging chinese guys yeah nothing
happened to him yeah this is exactly
like a seinfeld episode not that there's
anything wrong with you you're trying to
beat donald trump initially remember how
excited they got when they thought that
donald trump there was this false report
that he was watching
prostitutes peeing on furniture that was
covered you know like they were in a
greek apartment in detroit circa 60s it
was covered with the plastic wrap they
said he was watching russian prostitutes
peeing that was the big story they're
going to impeach him on that
and then we actually know that
copulation with chinese spies
on the regular with eric schwab nothing
oh this is worse than that they
impeached him for doing something that
we have
joe biden bragging that he did on camera
in ukraine that guy also farted
several times i hear yeah right while
he's speaking did you hear that well
listen
a certain when you're banging that many
chinese spies the push-ups that just
move the gas around here go with keegan
this is something this just goes to show
you how the media gets on uh they get
to continue along just uh lying
completely unfettered look we've talked
about uh what happened at the capitol
and i think that anybody who showed up
at the capitol with intent to commit
violence
is a problem okay i think that's a
problem and i think it was a very small
group of people
uh there have also been a lot of lies
and let me give you an example of a lie
yesterday
yesterday when someone was being
cross-examined by um
i'm included but you are uh so yesterday
the the senate they held a hearing
about the january 6th capital riot now
again terrible people who commit
violence it's terrible that
any people uh died tragically and that's
not what we do in
this country um but amy klummachar
club club klobuchar you know who i'm
talking about yeah the one nobody likes
the one nobody likes but who wasn't a
dark enough shade to warn a vp spot
um that's unfortunate she immediately
began through questioning
spreading lies tragically the attack on
the capital also cost the lives of three
brave officers
including officer brian signic who died
from injuries sustained while engaging
with protesters light
not true and i don't mean inaccurate
okay right
you either have to believe again
impossible that these people don't have
anyone who help
prepare them for these hearings before
they go out there uh or it's a lie and i
will tell you what
that is a lie that's a lie because on
monday sicknic's mother
said that what's going on i hear you
whispering over there it's like
spring you know he was like check yes
there's something going on with the
stream or something have we been removed
okay good we're good
on monday mother said that he did not
die of blunt force trauma
he died of a stroke okay that's what she
said on monday
don't remember don't forget either that
we talked about this on the day of the
attack
after the attack he uh texted his
brother after
he said that he'd been pepper sprayed
right but that he was overall in good
spirits
right typically doesn't happen if you've
been pans
labyrinthed in the face with a fire
extinguisher right this information's
only been public for six weeks though it
does take time for congress persons
i should say to get this here
and just you know this is one thing
again no accountability the new york
times had to retract we talked about
this their article
that originally claimed sicknick had
been bludgeoned to death with a fire
extinguisher
so they had to retract it yeah this is
this is an authoritative news source
also works great as tp in a pinch
because there's a shortage covered um
they say they had to retract it his own
family said well that's not true he
wasn't bludgeoned to death for the fire
extinguisher was it strokes of a fire
extinguisher
no none of that he just had a stroke so
the family authoritative news
have to after we've been talking about
this for many many days really for a
week beforehand they had to retract it
but then you have your democratically
elected leaders who are
able to speak is that is is that going
to be removed from twitter
is that going to be removed from from
youtube from facebook because we
that's verifiably false just like the
fact that these addresses didn't exist
is verifiably true it's not about the
law it's about whether the law is
applied
equally and if it were amy klobuchar
would be in one of biden's uh kids cage
camps that they just opened this week
exactly and it's also about making sure
that you're not just using these people
for political gain
the number keeps going down of people
that actually died from injuries related
to what happened there right are we do
we have anybody who actually died that
day from being killed by
somebody in the mob yeah do it i mean no
we don't i don't think we do
it went from three
this is i think the third uh either
heart attack or stroke now
as this has to be classified that was
not necessarily directly related to that
we had two officers commit suicide
all of these things are tragic by the
way terrible but you are standing up as
a representative
saying this is horrible because it
caused the deaths of these people and
i'm the person to come in here and fix
it and we hate republicans right right
that's what you're doing that's why
we're calling
you out on it because you're not being
honest with people about what actually
happened
don't sensationalize it just tell us
what happened yeah also the hairdo with
amy clinton that's that's
how does a company that lets you just
sign on with any made-up email and put
whatever face on
cares so much about authenticity right
yeah
they don't at certain points yeah it
doesn't make sense well yeah
why protect this narrative though in
such an obvious way because they want to
have the protection of being a
platformer not a publisher
i like that that's the answer no that's
what it is
you're not a publisher we're a platform
hold on is it a platform when you allow
amy klimachar
to spout a verifiable lie yeah and you
remove
i don't even want to say verifiable
truth you remove the process
of verifying truth that's what it was we
said let's go through the process when
we went into it we didn't know
and a big reason we had to do it was
because we looked at some of the claims
that were being made in court from some
of the trump attorneys and we said
that's not accurate
we can do better i thought it was
overkill i thought we had gone
so far above and beyond what we needed
to do there was no way they could take
it down it was like oh gosh if they take
this down they're just more oh oh they
took it down there they go yeah of
course
with her half bell hairdo is free to
stop yeah nobody's gonna fact check
that's like if you cut the cut the bell
of a notre dame in half
let's just put it on her head don't do
it emo phillips a little bit of emotion
a little bit yeah i think i took this
too far
um mrs butterfingers let's uh let's move
on to
this is something that the media is not
covering right now because they have
fouchy on there because that's all they
have
um swapping again we had this ready
because it was an article from
washington uh post i think maybe it was
wall street journal yeah
and then we noticed that cnn covered
this really really quickly going into a
break real fast and they didn't cover it
when they came back from a break
so before we go to the clip the first uh
migrant facility for kids
under joe biden oh opened up two days
ago
right now it's just buried in page 10.
here's cnn talking about it before a
break and i'm not really addressing it
again this happened this morning
so i've heard the administration's
explanations for this they say they need
more space to space these children out
due to the pandemic but i wonder in
practice
this administration is still importantly
are those kids at these migrant
facilities here how different is their
approach
in practice from the trump
administration approach
yes so unfortunately this is a reopening
of a temporary facility when we
think of temporary facilities we
remember facilities such as homestead
and these are widely criticized
facilities for lack of transparency
history of abuse
this is definitely concerning
unfortunately
it has to balance with prolonged custody
in cbp care
which has led to death of children so
there's
you know at this point um the the
solution has to be something different
president joe biden this is
he loves the kids by the way and to be
clear this is so we talked about this
when we uh did our change my mind on
immigration the the florence consent
the flores consent policy it was was it
97 or
93 someone can make sure that i'm right
on that i know it was under the clinton
era 97 it was 97.
uh and it decreed that children could
not be held in federal detention
facilities for any extended period of
time they must be placed in licensed
care programs or released to a relative
so look i don't this
the problem is those pictures that you
saw of those kids in cages right under
the trump administration
that was from the obama era that being
said the reason for it was because when
parents are committing a crime but the
kids aren't
you want to put the children in a
facility that is far more comfortable
than for the parents right uh and those
kids weren't in it's like a holding room
like tsa you know where they put on the
glove and they check you out and then
you're free to go yeah everyone else has
yeah yeah you want to bring five star
yeah yeah um that's that's really so i
want to be clear in that it was a double
standard from the left and i
i i don't think that anyone was really
at fault for this people were not
sleeping in cages uh
in underpasses on the freeway right all
brown children it was never true i don't
think that barack obama wanted to hurt
these children i don't think that donald
trump wanted to hurt these children
but the issue again is whether this is
applied
equally and this is what's interesting
they use it as political fighter they
use pictures from the obama
administration
kids in cages to lay it at the feet of
donald trump and say that he was a
racist
but now this is verifiably true okay
gitmo still open
these cages still exist by the way biden
was there when obama started them too
guy's got to get his money worth right
they spent something
one of the best lines in all of debate
history who built the cages joe
by the way that's rhetorical you
you built the cages i love that he said
it half a dozen times yeah
i was like come on man yeah come on
clown man
who about the cages joe i rest my case
so
uh saki jensaki was asked yesterday uh
specifically which
in a rare uh moment of journalistic
integrity about the inconsistency i
think this is from uh ducey oh are we
circling back
yeah are we circling uh she was asked
about the cages look at her
dancing here kamala harris said that
this facility putting people in this
facility was a human rights abuse
committed by the united states
government and jill biden said
under trump there have been horrifying
scenes of order
at the border of kids being kept in
cages now it's not under trump it's
under bible
this is not kids being kept in cages
this is
this is kids this is a facility that was
opened
that's going to follow the same
standards as other hhs facilities it is
not a replication
certainly not that's that is never our
intention of replicating the
immigration policies of the past
administration but we are in a
circumstance
where we are not going to expel
unaccompanied minors at the border
that would be inhumane that is not what
we are going to do here as an
administration
joe biden loves kids and if you play
your cards right he'll wrap your head in
duct tape and use you like a scratch and
sniff
yeah i feel like that there's going to
be a correction from cnn uh disneyland
el paso uh actually is open for children
come on exactly every kid will receive a
bushel basket and point it to an orange
tree
go collect the oranges go you can sell
them by the overpass
by the way what's interesting too i
think we have a collage here a lot of
democrats are getting buyers remorse
over biden
it's hilarious because they thought it
meant no more kids in cages but again
they paid for the cages they got their
money's worth it's like when you pay for
a movie and you know it's not going very
well but you want to see how it ends
i would say that only joe biden doesn't
have the attention span to finish the
whole film but he can just keep kids
he's not going to make it you don't use
them you don't get the tax write off
and uh of course listen i talked about
they were largely built under obama so
yeah this is one of those things they
paid for the cages who built the cages
joe
no one fact checked that because i just
ignored it i just said that that was
that that was untoward that it was a
little bit rude it was brash for donald
trump to say it
so this is what they do okay and then we
have to get going the best thing you can
do like i said is just comment
share this uh get it up on twitter
re-like these posts because
i i wouldn't give any information here
if i didn't believe in it 100
i would uh gladly go into court
regarding these issues of voter fraud
and make these claims and defend myself
and i would gladly lose my account if it
means so for the truth but here's what
they do they selectively apply the rules
and then when it's not a rule but it
comes down to like you said
an opinion at that point this is a
clinical diagnosis this is a rule and
this is my opinion
comes down to the rules they say well
you can't do this as it relates to
verifying
voter fraud which we did but you can do
this uh klobuchar
in making a verifiably false claim but
then it comes then it happens even
more i guess you would say it's more
subverse that
then it comes out of the opinions where
when they absolutely can't possibly fact
check donald trump in a debate says who
built the cages joe
that fact check should read like all the
other fact checks that you can see from
all these mainstream
websites in the debate is actually those
uh detention centers were created under
barack obama as a result to later the 97
floors consent policy
but instead what they do is they'll fact
check donald trump and ask him if he
uh if he uh denounces white supremacists
right and he said
well you said you said yes yes but then
you said stand by once and then instead
of
fact checking that joe biden in fact was
part of the administration that built
the cages
they just go donald trump was being
boorish so it's not just this is one
thing that people have always asked me
they say why don't you talk more about
like rachel matt i don't care about
msnbc i don't care about
uh salon outside of when they're
promoting actual pedophiles which they
did at salon and because of our
researchers we found them when the posts
got removed
because look i i don't care if someone
says that they're left i don't care if
someone has an opinion
what is far more corrosive to our
constitutional republic and you're
seeing this right now
with uh i want to say well no one really
cares about abc nbc
cnn anymore but uh twitter facebook
youtube amazon apple the people who
control all flow of information
is they want to tell you and they do
tell you
under a penalty of perjury which to me
there should be some accountability at
some point
that there is no bias that's the problem
think about this for a second
before donald trump there really is cnn
pre-trump and cnn post-trump
yeah i used to talk about cnn on this
show all the time back when was a blue
bed sheet nobody cared everybody why
don't you talk about msnbc well we know
where rachel maddow lines up
well how take a look
but anderson cooper don lemon chris
cuomo they were trying to present
themselves as journalists
that was exposed exclusively because of
donald trump even people who are liberal
who still tune into cnn they go
well you know what i tune in still to
cnn it's my preference but at least i
know what i'm watching
that's at least what needs to happen
with big tech when they are in control
of all information that reaches you
or that you send out that can reach
other people
and they create rules and guidelines
which are flagrantly
in opposition of the law this is what i
want to leave you with and then actually
we have a great segment with
choi junior falling asleep you think
he's a narcoleptic and we'll take your
chat
mug club livestream.com like hell is a
promo code you get 30
off so there's the law right of the
country
and then there are these social media
laws yeah
and here's the thing that i don't
understand because if they're a platform
if they're not a publisher they should
have to respect certain laws like
consent laws
so yeah we've had this happen i talked
about this on dave rubin's show
where you can follow the law entirely
and it is
in violation of social media guidelines
and then you can break
the law and it's acceptable let me give
you an example we've had videos where
we've done man in the street interviews
or we've done hidden camera interviews
uh this has happened not interviews but
hidden camera segments
this is what used to be known as
investigative journalism right you can
hear someone doing a crime you're having
a crime
you catch them and there are things uh
there are laws known as
consent laws meaning single party
consent states where most states are
single party consent states meaning you
don't need someone's permission
to film them or record a phone call we
have to do this research
when we do the show we'll go ah we can't
go do a change my mind here
because unless we get their signatures
and then if they recant we can't include
it so we have to be really careful about
that okay because we know these laws
really well have a half asian
entertainer
that couldn't afford the jew so but in
some states with consent laws you only
have to be 16.
this is true as well in quebec 14 thanks
dave oh
so single party consent laws so we've
had videos where we've gone out
we've interviewed people not even hidden
camera segments where we've interviewed
people
on camera who have said i am willing to
be on camera in
signed forms yeah and then gone to
youtube afterward and said you know what
i actually don't like what i said i want
to be taken down
and they tell us that we're violating
someone's privacy we say hold on a
second there is no reasonable
expectation of privacy in a public area
and we can send you this person on
camera in a written form saying they say
and they say you know what doesn't
matter we have our own laws because they
don't able to headache
guess what investigative journalism is
dead that would have been a hell of a
perk for nixon
think about that first time yeah exactly
well he's you know you caught him but he
says that he didn't get you didn't have
permission for that phone call
so the issue here is it's not only a
moving target with social media not
enforcing their laws their rules their
guidelines consistently but sometimes it
is in flagrant violation
of the laws in which their company is
founded
there is no way to do investigative
journalism
and i think what's so what's so sad to
me i wasn't mad about this i was really
sad because
i i had talked about this a long time
ago um
really back in 2009 i would say through
2012 that's why
a big part of why i left fox news was
because i thought well listen this is
going to new media where we don't need a
gatekeeper
and everyone was championing that saying
the good thing now is joe rogan was one
of the first podcasts
you don't need to be on uh the cable the
cable dial
for people to hear you there is no
gatekeeper anymore you can get your
information
directly to the public and that has
actually gotten worse because we went
from
three networks abc nbc cbs right and
that was it if you didn't make it there
no one
actually got to see you and then we had
a cable dial that expanded to thousands
of channels some of them are just music
channels i don't even know how that
works
and now we're back to five companies who
control
everything and they want to ensure that
you are
not able to reach people with the truth
and they don't even follow the law of
the united states
how does investigative journalism
survive how does fat checking
how does how do you fact check
how do you hold people accountable in
power
if everyone in power has created a
system outside of american laws
the foundation of a constitutional
republic if they've created a system in
which
they cannot be accountable how do you
hold them that was the main
perk was hey look we can call out
someone on abc nbc
look we can talk about a politician look
we're free to communicate here because
no one stops us
and now the people who are in control of
all information have guaranteed
that those in government and themselves
are not accountable
it's not that that's angering it is
that's really sad though
because that is i hate to leave it on
the snow but that is the downfall
of our republic and you know what i
think it's flawed i think it's a pretty
damn good country and i know this
because i grew up in canada and i have
an uncle right now who has kidney cancer
who had it since july
the reason he didn't know because his
forms fell next to the desk there's
socialized medicine for you you can't
fix that with a lawsuit
because there are no lawsuits all right
comment and after you know what we're
gonna
we're gonna perk this up and uh make fun
of our asian intern youtube thank you so
much i do appreciate credit for credits
too
you didn't remove us for posting this
because you knew that it was verified
twitter can go uh sit on attack that's
what they used to say at youth yeah the
devil doesn't like it he can sit on
attack
sit on an attack piss off youtube